Here’s a question.
What would you say is a drug trafficker’s
biggest dream?
Okay, allow me to explain myself.
We all have dreams-- you, me, politicians...
and of course, drug traffickers are no exception.
Though it may be hard to believe, in the heart
of the ruthless and cruel drug trafficking
industry, there are human beings with names,
surnames – and in this case also nicknames
– who like anyone else, also have dreams.
So let’s go back to my question...
What’s the biggest dream a drug trafficker
could have?
I mean, of course there might be many possible
answers--we’re all individuals.
But unfortunately... history tells us that
if most drug traffickers could make a wish,
just one wish... it’d be to turn their countries
into true narco-states.
That is to say, they would turn them into
states run by a kind of criminal corporation
made up of politicians, public officials,
judges, the police, and the military, which,
in one way or another, were associated with
drugs.
That way, drug traffickers could basically
act with impunity, exporting and distributing
narcotics without restriction.
Very recently, we spoke here, on VISUALPOLITIK,
about how the Bolivarian regime of Nicolás
Maduro, Diosdado Cabello and the “Cartel
de los Soles” was turning Venezuela into
a narco-state.
However, in Latin America, narco-politics
go far beyond Venezuela.
In this video we’ll find out a bit more
about how one character was able to promote
the alliance between the narcotics industry
and politicians.
Listen up.
(My best friends are in the Tugurios Community,
in the municipal dump)
(NARCOPOPULISM)
We all know it: the narcotics industry is
one of the most important illegal businesses.
Each year it moves several hundred billion
dollars.
Now, allow me to ask another question, do
you think that a cartel can survive without
political support?
Without controlling the institutions in any
way?
To answer this question, let's go back to
the beginning and take a look at how the most
important drug-dealers of all time managed
to do it...
Because even though it’s true that in the
beginning, drug traffickers started out as
little more than a band of outlaws, the time
came when all of this changed...
A time... and a protagonist:
Pablo Escobar Gaviria, considered by Forbes
Magazine to be one of the richest men of his
time on the entire planet.
According to Forbes, in 1987, Pablo Escobar
Gaviria, had a fortune that exceeded 2 billion
dollars at the time…
And Pablo Escobar radically changed the global
drug industry.
See, on the one hand, he created an entire
network, a criminal holding company that included
“business” like extortion, kidnapping,
hired killers and, of course, the main activity,
drug-trafficking.
All these activities were also perfectly integrated
into a structure, the Medellin Cartel, which
had a clear organizational chart, a well-defined
hierarchy, and even a zone-based distribution
network… each with its own managers.
Something like franchises or branches.
On the other hand, regarding his main business...
drugs… this Cartel, the Medellín Cartel,
achieved an almost complete vertical integration.
That is, the Cartel took over the harvest,
production, distribution and marketing of
the vast majority of its merchandise.
They did everything, took over every stage
of the business.
That’s how the Medellín Cartel managed
to invoice more than 7 billion dollars per
year.
Of course... none of this would’ve been
possible without the complicity of the public
authorities.
( “Apparently Escobar reached the top of
the cocaine cartel by astutely reinvesting
his initial earnings and becoming a PR master
in Colombia [...] With his growing wealth,
Escobar bought a newspaper in Medellín, gained
influence in Colombian politics and he successfully
ran for public office, becoming an alternative
to the national congress.”
David Henry, Forbes Magazine 1987.)
See, for many years Pablo Escobar had impunity.
With his money and threats – the well-known
phrase of silver or lead – he managed to
infiltrate the Colombian State.
He bribed the military, politicians, governors,
the police... in such a way that many Colombian
institutions were under his command for a
long time.
And that's not all.
Pablo Escobar also financed electoral campaigns,
and to win popular support – What does a
politician do when he wants to gain popularity
fast – he promoted projects such as building
houses for the nation’s poorest citizens,
distributing provisions, and creating soccer
fields.
Sounds good, doesn’t it?
At first glance... a Colombian Robin Hood.
Too bad the truth was so different.
While he was carrying out this type of campaign,
he had no qualms about flooding the streets
with violence and blood.
Welcome to Narcopopulism.
The case is that, as you all know...
Pablo Escobar... managed to hold a seat in
the Colombian Parliament in 1982.
Until then, thanks to his “political influences”
and his PR strategies, he was able to build
his empire and his huge fortune with the utmost
impunity.
(AUDIO: “A member of the United States Drug
Enforcement Agency once said that importing
exotic animals for his zoo caused Escobar
more problems with the government than his
drug business.”
David Henry)
Now... just a second.
Don’t think that Pablo Escobar’s “political
relations” were limited to Colombia, not
at all.
See… after being elected as deputy... the
situation became untenable.
Some members of the media began to tell the
truth hiding behind his fortune; the DEA’s
pressures multiplied, a lot of Colombian society
understood the huge danger that Pablo Escobar
entailed and other cartels began to fear that
the power of Medellín would grow even more.
And that's when the government began to persecute
this capo... which declared war on the Colombian
state itself.
And just in case, the first thing Escobar
did was leave the country, lest he be hunted.
(THE LEAP)
So Pablo Escobar put some space between himself
and Colombia.
The question is, where could he find refuge?
Would his drug-money be enough to strengthen
alliances?
Well… it seems so.
First of all, Panama...
At that time, the military dictator Manuel
Antonio Noriega offered him asylum, protection
and a route to transport his merchandise.
Imagine, this industry was so powerful that
even dictators were willing to sell their
services.
The fact is that, as you can see, Noriega
also turned Panama into a narco-state, until
in 1989, a lightning invasion by the United
States removed him from power...
Detained and transferred to the United States,
Noriega was sentenced to 30 years in prison
for his crimes in drug-trafficking... and
his relationship with the Medellin Cartel.
But... no, Pablo Escobar Gaviria’s external
alliances didn’t end here.
The truth is that he didn’t feel very safe
in Panama...
Let's see, yes, Noriega was a pal so to speak…
but the CIA had a big presence in the country...
so when he least expected it, Noriega could
be tempted to sell him out.
Because, of course, it was one thing to do
business with a Panamanian dictator and quite
another to entrust him with his protection.
He needed to find a new destination.
So through the left-wing Colombian guerrilla
Movement, on April 19, better known as M-19,
Pablo Escobar contacted the Nicaraguan government.
At that moment, the Sandinista Government
Board, led by the country’s current president
Daniel Ortega, was willing to welcome him
with open arms in exchange for a commission...
you know, for services rendered.
The agreement specified that, in addition
to settling in the country with his family,
Pablo could use some of Nicaragua’s regions
as a drug-distribution platform.
The problem?
Ortega and his friends were very greedy...
so a few months later Pablo decided to return
to Colombia.
But of course, he maintained his business
relations.
But, there’s more.
Along with Nicaragua, the M-19 guerrilla also
facilitated the Medellin Cartel’s contact
with the Cuban government…
Yes, you heard that right, Cuba was also a
trading platform for Pablo Escobar's businesses.
In fact, it’s known that Pablo Escobar maintained
good relations with the Castro brothers.
Although, truthfully, it seems that he wasn’t
the only one.
All evidence indicates that after Escobar,
other drug-dealers continued to use Cuba,
through the Castros, to introduce all types
of narcotics into the United States.
Anyway, Colombia, Panama, Nicaragua, Cuba...
As you can see, political power was one of
the main drivers of the huge presence of drug
trafficking in Latin America.
The lack of transparency, corruption, lack
of counterweights and weak institutions were
a perfect breeding ground for what over the
years became one of the great nightmares of
the region.
And yes, some of you may be thinking... well,
okay Simon... but in the end Pablo Escobar
fell from power.
It's true, but when a capo falls, it doesn’t
mean that the industry falls… nor do their
relations with political power.
Let's take a look at Mexico.
(THE RELAY)
The main Mexican cartel with which Pablo Escobar
had a relationship was the Guadalajara Cartel,
led by Ernesto Fonseca, Rafael Caro Quintero
and Miguel Ángel Felix Gallardo.
This cartel had full impunity for 2 decades...
all thanks to their relations with people
in power.
See, Felix Gallardo was in charge of “public
relations”... and thanks to his ability
to move within the highest political spheres,
this Cartel had all the stability it needed
to grow and develop.
PR is so important!
However, we’re talking about a criminal
industry, and in criminal organizations stability
is very hard to achieve.
In this case, the assault on the DEA agent,
Enrique Camarena, which ended his life, made
Washington demand the dismantling of this
cartel... and its leaders fell one by one.
But... this didn’t end the business.
From prison, in 1989, Felix Gallardo tried
to reorganize the territories... but in the
absence of an agreement the Cartel split in
two:
The Tijuana Cartel led by the Arellano brothers
and the Sinaloa Cartel led by Héctor Luis
Palma Salazar “El güero Palma” and Joaquín
Guzmán Loera, aka “el Chapo”, who debuted
on the Forbes list in 2009 with an estimated
fortune of more than 1 billion dollars.
The fact is that under el Chapo’s command,
the Sinaloa Cartel became the most important
and influential cartel in Mexico and one of
the most important criminal organizations
in the world.
The question that many of you may be asking
is…
How did he do it?
How can one Cartel grow so much more than
its adversaries?
Well, above all... because of political influences.
For example, how do you prevent the federal
police from catching you and dismantling your
business?
Well... by for example finding out when those
raids will happen.
Everything is based on good relations... and
that’s precisely what El Chapo made sure
he’d have.
Information and “friends” are power.
And, as we’ve seen in other cases, El Chapo’s
capture didn’t really change the panorama.
Today, the Sinaloa Cartel is controlled by
Ismael “el Mayo” Zambada, who, over the
years, has been known to buy officials from
the Special Prosecutor's Office, the Attorney
General's Office and even the Counter-Narcotics
Intelligence Center, an elite army corps created
to fight narcos.
(“Obviously they don’t do these businesses
alone, in many cases they have the approval
or participation of the authorities”, F.J.R
researcher at the University of Guadalajara)
All in complicity with senior government officials.
Only that explains these criminal groups’
power, strength and resilience.
We’re talking about a political power with
which, in many cases, narcos create a symbiosis
that is hard to distinguish.
That’s what’s happening in Venezuela with
the Soles Cartel, of which we’ve already
spoken here on VISUALPOLITIK.
And watch out, because it’s estimated that
the Mexican and Venezuelan cartels control
70% of all the drugs that enter the United
States.
That’s what happens in countries like Guatemala,
where some sources state that up to 80% of
all the white powder could be mediated by
members of the national army itself; or what’s
happening in Honduras, where even the son
of former President Porfirio Lobo has been
condemned in the United States for drug trafficking
activities while his father, his own father,
was President of the Republic.
Anyway, folks, that’s the result of weak
institutions, a lack of transparency and a
lack of counterweights.
On VISUALPOLITIK we’ll talk much more about
this issue which is becoming very expensive
for many Latin American countries.
With this video we wanted to show you a few
examples of how some of the great narcos “succeeded”
so well, largely thanks to their influence
on established institutions.
So I really hope you enjoyed this video, please
hit like if you did, and don’t forget to
subscribe for brand new videos.
Don’t forget to check out our friends at
the Reconsider Media Podcast - they provided
the vocals in this episode that were not mine.
Also, this channel is possible because of
Patreon, and our patrons on that platform.
Please consider joining them and supporting
our mission of providing independent political
coverage.
And as always, I’ll see you in the next
video.